Fox News Alert brand new video showing
two Israeli hostages who were released
by Hamas receiving medical attention in
Egypt that comes as the Biden
Administration reportedly pressures
Israel to delay its ground Invasion into
Gaza let's get to Mike Tobin right away
he's standing by with the very latest in
southern Israel as this broke just
before we came to air hi
Mike hi Dana the Red Cross confirmed it
now we have some uh visual confirmation
with a video being released by the alaka
news agency showing these two Israeli
hostages being loaded into ambulances on
the Egyptian side of the Rafa Crossing
should be noted that Israel won't
confirm their release until they are
back in Israel Israeli hands but nitz
and Y yitzak are out of the Gaza Strip
out of Hamas captivity Hamas said they
were released on humanitarian grounds
there is a reporting or information
anyway to the effect that they are in
bad Health uh there was reports
throughout the day suggesting there were
deals cooking uh that would involve the
release of 50 of the hostages held in
the Gaza Strip uh sources talking with
our Aisha hne uh said it's more like 70
to 90 foreign Nationals with a prospect
of being released through negotiations
Israel said that they're not concerned
about what passport someone holds
they're interested in seeing the release
of all 222 of the prisoners also
information released or that leak was
leaked from the negotiations uh
suggested that a ceasefire was part of
the discussion but Israel is not
interested in a ceasefire Dana Mike
thank you so much when the release of
two more hostages comes as the Biden
Administration faces new questions over
reports that it put into the media that
it has been privately urging Israel to
delay the ground Invasion into Gaza the
administration trying to buy more time
for the hostage negotiations but
publicly the White House says that it is
not their business to tell Israel what
to
do we're not dictating military terms to
the Israeli Defense Forces they have a
right and a responsibility to go after
these terrorists and they certainly are
are going to do it in a way that they
choose to that they believe is
appropriate to the threat but we're not
dictating terms to them we agree that
the top priority has got to be going
after Hamas there's no there's no
daylight here we also think it's
important for humanitarian assistance to
flow and for our hostages to get home
with their families and we're working
all three of those things and President
Biden getting asked about a potential
ceasefire and it seems like he messed up
his words a
bit supporting the hostages for
ceasefire deal why did you we should get
we should have a cease fire not a ceas
fire we should have to be and then we
can talk
any that's just can I
just point a personal privilege for just
a second the commander-in-chief of the
United States if you are going to answer
that question do it at the microphone
phone so the world can hear you that's
important not when you're walking away
not when you're trying not to take
questions that's an important question
and it's an important answer okay point
of personal privilege done Greg yes may
I turn to you please well I I have to
say it was it's nice to see that that
elderly woman smiling and that she's
alive and I think you know I suspect
like a lot of people Hamas is using
hostage negotiations as a way to put off
their own deaths but what do I know you
know I'm a magazine editor so I I I I
think that these questions like whether
America is having reportedly trying to
delay ground
invasions you know I don't know and this
the moment by moment coverage puts us in
this constant speculation mode about
stuff that we know zilch about so I
don't know anything about ground forces
or strategies or tunnels uh every
opinion that I I seem to hear is not
anybody's own you know they armchair
analysts coming up with stuff I still
think that we should step back it's like
we're watching water boil right now
Israel has decided its course and that
course will come and what will happen
now and what will happen later is for
reasons that none of us will probably
know until it happens I mean you could
argue that this whole thing the the the
delay is actually a clever front story
that maybe there are some things going
on that we don't know about I get tons
of emails from viewers and they think
they've struck on some kind of original
solution you know FL the tunnels gas the
tunnels we're all getting these emails
as if these ideas didn't occur already
from the ID the bottom line is you
should be skeptical skeptical of what
you hear because it's what you don't
hear that matters so obsessing over
ground invasions is going to keep us
busy but the players involved have
already moved on and are doing something
out else and they might be using the
confusion and the quote waiting you know
uh as something uh involving creating
the best environment for the most
Innovative response something we aren't
aware of and again I mean for people
like us who are not there you know we
should be thinking past this what comes
after I keep mentioning a coalition of
Arab countries with the help of Israel
to fix this thing after after because
you can't go back what's done is done
obsessing over the past is a losers game
October 7th is the start of this story
and Israel repaired to finish it and
judge it's interesting because when you
look at something like the New York
Times and with a headline like that with
the sourcing that it had it's just like
that phrase that you if you see a turtle
on a fence post it didn't get there on
its own somebody put it there and so
they have you know it wired so that they
could tell the media what they want to
say from the administration but then
publicly they say that they're strong
right you know what's interesting about
this is the fact that um if if this
country and it peers it is is telling
Israel to slow down telling him we've
got to get Aid to the hostages uh uh uh
Aid to the Palestinians release the
hostages think about it we had two
hostages released last week two hostages
released today there are 220 hostages if
we had two a week we're in this for 110
weeks okay talk about a Slowdown talk
about a delay uh look Israel wants these
hostages as much if not more than
everyone else it's their neighborhood
they know what to do they know what it's
like and Dana this is now a regional War
this is not just Hamas and Israel this
is Hezbollah where Israel is evacuating
people from the north on the border of
Lebanon there are daily fights in the
West Bank uh Americans have been shot at
in uh Syria and Iraq nine soldiers
injured one contractor who died of a
heart attack apparently and Kirby has
indicated that those attacks are by an
Iranian backed militia we've got the US
intercepting long range missiles from
Yemen and we've also got China moving
warships to the Middle East so now this
is more than a regional war and you know
and no one knows better than Israel how
to handle it what they're up against but
I spoke to someone in the IDF today and
this is what he said to me he said the
White House military advisers are
Consulting and they're they're over in
Israel now he said we need ammo we need
those interceptors for the Drone he said
in the nine months we're going to have a
problem and we need America so America
can say we've got hands off but they
know that in terms of what Israel needs
they're going to have to listen and my
final point is this you know
humanitarian efforts cannot delay a
Justified response on the part of Israel
350 to 500,000 Germans were killed by
the Allied Forces in World War II nobody
said hey we got to stop we can't kill
any Germans they said we've got to stop
Hitler and that's how it worked and so
right now people are suffering at the
hands of amas this is getting bigger and
bigger it's time for Israel to say our
war we didn't wake up on October 7th and
decide we were going to attack Hamas
they started this we need to finish it
Jessica what are your thoughts
today my thoughts are that I agree with
what Greg was saying and we were talking
about this on Friday as well that there
are people who are much better informed
than us that are pulling the strings
here and hopefully it is not 110 weeks
and that we go maybe two two a day would
be nice and maybe there's going to be a
flood everybody tomorrow I would love
5mon old baby in
there it is excruciating the details of
that of what has happened and what I'm
sure continues to go on and that was a
major theme I noticed of the weekend's
coverage if you saw the spokesperson for
the Israeli government held a briefing
for journalists who doubt their stories
and showed them all of the profane
footage I mean I was particularly Trey
Ying was interviewing a rescue worker
who said that Hamas gouged a man's eyes
out cut off his wife's breasts chopped
their daughter's leg off nothing is
going to stop Israel from hunting down
these sadistic Savages who did this so
they know what they're doing but we are
also helping more than whatever that
kind of bumbling response from Biden
axios just reported a story an hour ago
saying that we have an American three
star general on the ground we have
Military Officers there that are
training IDE
uh soldiers in how we would approach
this there is a ground Invasion being
prepared and the beginnings of it
already started and some of the most
complex hostage negotiations that we've
seen and BB is really suffering over
there I mean the polling out of Israel
is astounding so 80% of Israelis want BB
to take public responsibility for this
and he already has people high up in his
government that have come out and
publicly apologized for missing no he's
run away he doesn't meet with the
families he wears his little vest around
and doesn't go where he's supposed to go
and I understand he's embarrassed about
what he did with the Judiciary and that
IDF soldiers had to be on the other side
of the country because of the mess that
he caused but you these people are dead
now and they need your support and they
need you to take public responsibility
for what has happened and try to mend
this especially if you want some sort of
political future now you agree with
Trump yeah here we go BB's a big loser
I'm like
prime time well I don't know anything
about Israeli politics but I do know Joe
Biden's not cut out to be
commander-in-chief you have to be
precise when you speak about war and the
man does not have it Jessica in the last
72 hours he said oh let's do a ceasefire
let's not do a ceasefire let's negotiate
for hostages let's I don't know what the
policy is do you know what the I have no
idea no you don't because he doesn't
because the policy changes every single
day Jessica there's a lot of pressure on
him right now but there's a lot of
pressure throughout the region and we're
advertising we're under pressure I see
leaks every day in axio saying the
administration is panicked over World
War I now why are we even talking to
reporters about how panicked we are
about World War III we're admitting
we're running low on weapons we're
admitting we have no idea how many
hostages there I mean this is not this
is what you say you say the United
States will do everything we possibly
can to defend our allly lies and our
interests in the reason that's it and
you say if anybody messes with us
they'll face the full force of the US
Military and you say nothing else and
it's like everybody's just kind of like
just speaking about how they're feeling
all of the time to the media my God it's
embarrassing now it looks like what
happened here was that Biden was caught
out of posture in the midd East when he
was elected he pulled these defense
batteries the anti-missile defense
systems the Patriots out and now he has
to rush them back in in and they're not
there yet so he's telling BBY to slow
down and don't go ground because we're
not ready for this to escalate because
if this escalates with Iranians and
Hezbollah before we have our defense in
there then we're going to get caught and
we're going to get hurt so that's the
delay the longer this delay goes on the
better it is for Hamas and the better it
is for Hezbollah and the better it is
for the Iranians not only are they
winning the so-called PR war with these
hostage releases you should see how
these releases are being covered in Al
jazer I mean they're they're making it
like these people are the diplomats
these people are the humanitarians and
if we would just do a ceasefire we could
settle this thing all together like that
also if you're bombarding Northern Hamas
with artillery and you're not going in
on the ground you're just having
Palestinians and Hamas people with
little video cameras and their phones
film it make it look like it's
indiscriminate and then blast it out to
the entire world and the Squad is saying
it's indiscriminate you have us members
of Congress saying this is
indiscriminate bombing these are war
crimes meanwhile there's surgical
strikes targeting strongholds but
they're but they're losing face in the
region they're also letting the Iranians
arm up Hezbollah how many how many
shipments are going across the desert
right now that we can't even track they
need to go in and I am not a military
expert Greg the longer this goes on the
worse it is for Israel no question hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now